hier après midi un dernier hommage était
rendu à igor et grichka bogdanoff lors
de leurs funérailles à l'église de la
madeleine à paris c'était très émouvant
parce que justement c'était là c'était
la suite de l'histoire et à trop tôt
mais il est très belle parmi les
personnalités présentes sur place le
chanteur francis lalanne amis des deux
frères est aussi connu pour ses
positions anti vaccins gouvernement est
en train d'attenté à la santé des
françaises et des français selon le
parisien si tous les invités étaient
bien masqué il est le seul à avoir
refusé de porter le masque à l'intérieur
de l'église il est par ailleurs revenu
sur les liens qui l'unissaient avec igor
et grichka notamment sur le refus de se
faire vacciner j'ai fait le même choix
encore un point de vue qu'ont partagé
ensemble ce n'est pas un vaccin mais un
traitement expérimental qui ne procurent
pas l'immunité il a conclu en affirmant
que le vaccin aurait rien changé à leur
destin ça ne les aurais pas protégé
alors funérailles des bogdanoff francis
lalanne aurait refusé de porter son
masque dans l'église bat-il trop loin
valérie oui oui parce que il a le droit
de penser ce qu'il veut sur le vaccin il
a le droit de pas se vacciner passé sont
probants et la droite a raison voilà
vraiment on est dans une cérémonie
religieuse dans un endroit clos là pour
le coup qu'on soit pour ou contre le
vaccin c'est pas la question on sait que
dans un endroit clos le sait le virus
circule donc voilà la moindre des
politesses pour pas créer d'esclandre
c'est un moment qui est solennel c'est
un an un enterrement on se masse qu'on
n'essaie pas de faire à ce moment-là un
moment politique d'un moment religieux
quoi les mulets renard n'est pas
d'accord mon coeur et la raison sauf
qu'il est dans sa logique ouais il est
dans sa logique donc voilà il va
jusqu'au bout de sa logique donc
évidemment je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec john c moi je trouve que
c'est un clown mais en revanche il est
dans sa logique donc je ne suis même pas
choquer d'accord dafy cement moi je les
adore un francis mais là il en fait s'il
va trop loin d'autant plus que les
bogdanoff du coville oui je lèche
l'adorent j'aime beaucoup celle là
beaucoup maladroite pas d'accord avec
oui mais là je suis trop loin ça ne sert
à rien et en plus y avait quand même
beaucoup de monde donc donc il y aura pu
mettre son masque tout simplement oui
moi je suis d'accord un enterrement sans
nom de deuil de recueillement mais c'est
pas lui qui crée une polémique c'est les
gens c'est les médias qui sont venus le
voir et l'embêter avec ça elle demandé
pourquoi vous portez
inapproprié c'est inapproprié pour un
enterrement et sur le fond puisque
maintiennent polémique je trouve que ce
qui dit bien au moment du décès des
bogdanoff on a une espèce de
récupération et de propagande entre
guillemets pro bac sont tombés voilà ils
sont pas fait vacciner c'est aussi bien
d'entendre publiquement des gens qui
disent voilà moi je ne suis pas vacciné
et je n'ai pas peur donc je trouve ça
bien qu'il est si la sphère d'accord
avec avec delphine il est dans sa
logique mais c'est une logique de hors
la loi c'est un rebelle de pacotille ses
impostures celle que du politique et
excuse moi guillaume je suis très choqué
par ta génération des hors la loi toi tu
respecte pas la loi qu'on alors je veux
dire merci porte une chemise comme com
ou cas on l'a dit mais convoque à la vie
toi tu la respectes moi tu la respectes
pas mais quand il ya aussi des gens qui
ont du recul par rapport à l'alouette
japon 1-0 passé ridicule et absurde mais
apporte non dans une église c'est pas
absurde parce que c'est un lieu clos
d'accord d'accord mais excuse moi il
faut pas vénérer d'être hors la loi tu
dois respecter la loi et j'espère que tu
respecte la loi parce que sinon ça me
fait beaucoup ça me fait peur d'être à
côté de toi oui bah oui c'est ça mon nom
c'est katia mariens on est traités comme
des pestiférés pas d'y
laisser parler tu mets pas de maj me
recule à telco vite c'est dégueulasse je
me recule ce soir et on voit les gens en
chine la demande à quand un recul mais
si tu as le taux de la même semaine je
ne recule pas ouais parce que maman je
suis négatif et ya des règles à jour non
mais je les bats 10 le connais je pense
qu'il faut respecter la loi je pense que
tu dis qu'il faut pas respecté la loi je
pense qu'il faut respecter ce que la
loin sans cesse que la loi d'aujourd'hui
était la loi d'il ya deux ans non loin
un sens non elle n'a aucun sens mais
d'ascq ont emporté pas à l'extérieur il
ya six mois mais un saut dans chaque
mois tu vas voter il va y avoir un
changement de gouvernement puisque tout
le monde est contre ce gouvernement est
percée notamment dans les sondages ce
n'est pas le cas rare mais non mais
comme tout le monde en a l'air de dire
ici sur ce plateau ce que c'est wayne
des cours dans les sondages on voit que
le président obama la plus dangereuse
d'abandon est gênant c'est comme ça la
loi va changer tu pourras ne plus mettre
de match tu pourras ne plus près de
présenter tout ce que tu veux mais si tu
es mon maître de celui
[Rires]
qu'on vient nous pour l'odeur mais ces
tournois vous contentez la situation
actuelle où trouvé ça super de mettre
des masses vous trouvé ça super de tenir
à distance c'est donc juste
horrible mais ne pas m'être ne pas
mettre à mal dans un dans des lieux clos
aujourd'hui j'estime que zemma bien moi
je trouve que c'est un geste fort alors
que c'est dans un hôpital qui va
permettre de masquer ouais super singe
est vespa un hôpital c'est un
enterrement et d y est dans la rue et
l'aï détour sur la photo il était à
l'intérieur dans l'église et il y avait
beaucoup de personnes y avait plus de
sens afin d'y aller en prison non j'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait qu'il aille en
bagnole john beck la loi vu justement
c'est un vrai geste de provocation
déploré dégueulasse parce que il va
quand même et l'enterrement de deux
personnes qui sont mortes ducobu vide et
il ne m'est pas de masse qui met en
danger tous les gens qui sont autour de
lui je trouve ça scandaleux en peluche
et âge et pourtant j'ai beaucoup aimé
francis lalanne mais là il dit vraiment
et en plus il a quand même fait des
déclarations en disant que même s'ils
avaient été vaccinés n'aurait pas été
plus protégés je suis désolé il se sert
de la mémoire de ces de ses frères
bogdanoff qu'il n'avait pas fait état de
leur non vaccination si ça m'était des
antilles vax convaincu et qu'ils avaient
essayé de de faire du prosélytisme ok
ils pouvaient s'inscrire dans ça mais là
je suis désolé il se sert de la mort de
ces gens qui ont été discrets qui ont
fait un choix personnel et pour en faire
une polémique f t on à nouveau ssd
d'isabelle morini-bosc elle est vraiment
très très bonne cette place
est vraiment très très bonne cette
[ __ ] attaques doivent finir par
prendre ma place
les alexandre
oui ils tous d'accord avec une grande
partie de son intervention parce que
autant le fait ne pas porter le masque
on peut discuter il a sans doute tort
mais sur les déclarations excusez moi il
est dans le vrai de bout en bout il
connaissait les bogdanoff il connaît
leur choix il sait ce qu'ils ont fait il
assume je trouve ça très bien là c'est
pas du militantisme c'est de la vérité
ce qu'il dit et je trouve ça bien qu'il
ait pu le dire à ce moment là voilà
guillaume toi le premier qui est un peu
contre le principe des vaccins et 2 et
de te dire que quand tu es vacciner tu
peux continuer à transmettre donc on est
bien d'accord que justement le masque ça
peut servir et ça fait barrière même
s'il ya plein de vacciner dans une salle
mais au moins c'est almas mais je pense
que lui sain au delà du fait de ma
portée de masse c'est un geste fort il
veut envoyer un message et juré
découvrira pas de la disparition des
bogdanoff c'est pas vrai c'est les gens
qui ont fait de la récupération là
dessus vous ne vous souvenez pas
quelques heures après leur décès y avait
déjà des gens entrent et qui est en
train de leur faire la morale donc oui
il a répondu à ça il a dit voilà moi
j'ai fait le choix comme eux de ne pas
être vaccinés moi je suis en bonne santé
je pense moi qui emmerdent les autres en
fait des gens nés en cee qui sont
emmerdés
car ils sont traités comme des moins que
rien qu'on empêche de vivre toute la
journée donc c'est bien que des gens
aussi garni sorte la voix de ces femmes
qui se sentent mis à l'écart voilà c'est
une personnalité publique et la droit de
le faire tout en me like a reproduit au
lancement non mais je pense qu'il ya
plein de gens qui sont mises à l'écart
qui ne peuvent plus travailler qui ne
peuvent plus sortir qui sont traités
comme des moins que rien qui sont mis à
l'écart et compris sur les plateaux télé
fin c'est complètement absurde et c'est
bien qu'ils aient des gens qui les
hantent et aux obsèques de magna
n'aurait pas mille masques j'ai pas été
invités à méditer a incité si jérémy
hamas mais ces soirées non plus mais
c'est bien c'est bien de donner un peu
de voir ces gens là c'est pas parce
qu'on reçoit une information et un ordre
de porter un masque il faut faire ce
qu'on demande on peut aussi avoir du
recul sur ce qui se passe et un avis bas
analyser les situations avoir un avis un
esprit pratique en fait s'il fait les
sociétés à dire n'importe quoi
d'accord
je me suis un peu adouci sur ceux qui
sont un peu mis à l'écart et je
comprends que dans s'interroge mais dans
ce cas précis on sait qu'une chose qu'on
fait pas grand chose on sait que le
masque en public dans un lieu fermé il
faut le mettre et s'est passé ces deux
là c'est de la révolte à deux balles ça
n'a aucun intérêt voilà ça n'a aucun
intérêt
en fait parce que bon on peut maintenant
entendre que dans doute voilà
effectivement on sait qu'avec le
vacciner en peul on peut l'avoir peut
l'attraper on peut transmettre on peut
le sens de cette ville dont le sommet
benjamin vous balayer ça d'un trait de
plume un rib à l'oeil c'est un symbole
vous prenez pas là où je rejoins
guillaume c'était un symbole que
français ça regardez la photo derrière
des symboles mais on ne voit qu'une fois
de plus les faits par les juifs la force
des symboles est importante mais qui
sauvent peut ne pas être d'accord sur
tout mais il représente une partie des
français est en chemin il envoya un bal
j'aime
bien
les gars il ramait kapusta
voyais un jacuzzi ont-ils alors ça l'a
fait la fontaine de trevi est contente
du gdp
symbole puisque le masa sous le regard
des gens et on fait tout ça n'a aucun
sens parce que ça change tout le temps
on peut porter des masques à l'intérieur
on peut plus emporté on doit reporter
c'est n'importe quoi
mais voilà
enchanté je veux bien que dans la rue il
n'y a pas de souci mais il met pas son
masque là il va rentrer dans une église
venue clos monde ça va être dans un lieu
fermé qu'il cérémonie c'est un décès il
met pas son match il cherche une
provocation et dans un lieu ouvert norme
est d'accord mais ça nous ennuie ouvert
est d'accord mais symbole de quoi ya pas
de samba il a paradé chercher un symbole
sûr je suis persuadé que si demain il
fait un concert et qu'on lui dit 500
personnes pour que tu te produisent mais
les gens mettent leurs masques il va
dire d'accord les gens mettent leur
masse tant que je peux chanter il n'y a
pas de symbole là dedans y'a juste une
provocation inutile la punit breton qui
se vaccinent pas c'est son choix et la
raison mais n'en mène pas les gens comme
ça a dit regardez moi j'ai pas mis de
masse surtout surtout ce jour là mais le
ce jour là c'est
rechanter en plus c'est gentil thonon
alors j'aime bien moi j'aime bien ces
titres à l'époque je n'ai pas mais si
vous savez aujourd'hui dans une salle
avec 1000 personnes il ferait comme tous
les autres artistes là la liberté il en
a plus rien à [ __ ] des gens m alors
masquer les chanterelles
raymond c'est le symbole de sa fidélité
au bogdanov jusqu'au bout c'est ça
qu'ils font mais c'est ça qu'il faut
voir vous il a rêvé liens indéfectibles
avec eux et franchement vous pouvez ne
pas être d'accord mais la manière dont
voulions jeu mais michel bonfils vous
avez milité chauriens les vrais de
sociabilité
ils ont pas de filets maillants jamais
ces manifestations savoir il est pas
manifestation là il est
jusqu'à maintenant tu dis n'importe quoi
et je suis chez moi c'est beaucoup
de ces discours du corps mais dès
qu'il y en ait un doute et qu'on puisse
interroger mais dans ce cas précis
qui médite
les mecs c'est un peu nous on l'a fait
[Musique]
sur le match franchement tu as tort
c'est stupide le vaccin est le masque
c'est pas le même c'est la même chose
rien à voir c'est pas la même chose moi
je suis contre le vaccin je suis pas
contre le masque c'est pas vraiment la
même chose la trappe et c'est avoir peur
du vaccin c'est pas se protéger en
mettant un masque même cette image là
cette photo-là cette symbolique là ce
discours là c'est pour tous les millions
de francs chouih qui aujourd'hui se
sentent mis à l'écart je dis pas qu'il a
raison sur tout mais c'est vraiment pour
lui
c'est à dire de les représenter je
connais un projet d'ajustement
appréciable patricia non justement c'est
très dangereux parce que on est quand
même en train de demander à des gamins
de mettre le masque d'or dans le rock
classe c'est hyper contraignent enfin on
peut pas imaginer ce que c'est et voilà
ce monsieur et en plus c'est un
privilégié je suis désolé ce serait un
lambda on lui aurait choix de donner 135
euros damende leur ai dit de mettre le
lac donc à il papa
[Applaudissements]
giresse à la dérive qui dit ils
applaudissent vraiment cette [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
des plus paisibles bonheur de son nez au
tribunal
on est au tribunal on désigne les bons
et les mauvais citoyens non vous là on
est dans un lieu que l'on n'a pas de
masque vous quand vous faites vos
petites soirées vos petits trucs chez
vous avait pas de la fédé soirée une
carte mais tout le monde sait des
soirées arrêté que les intérêts des
pouvoirs combat ce soir et depuis deux
ans alors c'est vrai
mais arrêtez de vous indigner dès que
vous voyez quelqu'un sinon masse comme
s'ils étaient en train de commettre un
crime atroce ça va il a pas de masse et
justin une position et une sorte de
révolte face à ce qui se passe en sort
une posture pas raison c'est un geste
fort et arrêter de faire les hypocrites
harper vous mais vous ne portez pas de
masse toute la journée à part quand vous
êtes joueur et que vous êtes devant les
gens arrêter d'être hypocrite
[Applaudissements]
isabelle ou animale je suis rassuré la
police tout le monde en fait
or ces téléspectateurs oui ça a cessé
c'est serré comme un café eux voient
dans cette photo bien c'est plutôt
regarder mais il ya beaucoup de noms
quand même un voile à guillaume parce
que guillaume est seul sur le bateau
mais vous l'avez guillaume a raison mais
pas par la page et on voit mal à mes
amis dit vous êtes tous au restaurant
entre à manger vous vous mettrez
tranquille ce sondage est là parce que
c'est une église et parce que c'est un
espoir avec un masque est alors mais
alors mais ça change quoi céder leur
manger avec un
message c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
la belle sofia haute tension mais que
les que les règles je n'ai aucun sens
mais sauf que c'est une règle que c'est
la loi qu'on applique tout ce qu'on nous
dit même si sanogo bref la mine alors
comment j'ai envie de rouler à 250
kilomètres heure mais tout ça n'a rien à
voir tu meurs pas
non non tu meures perdre tout le monde
ne meurt pas et heureusement d'ailleurs
heureusement
terminé nos règles qui n'ont aucun sens
mais toi voilà parce que j'ai pas le
choix parce que voilà et c'est à partir
à new york taka pas faire plus j'étais
contraint oui je suis contraint de faire
certaines obame et ses toiles et j'ai
besoin d'avoir un avis là dessus mais
sait pas s'il se plie pas il va faire
quoi il réfléchit à
gré de tolérance c'est insupportable a
dit m
les gens qui font parler dans un instant
de façon parce que géraldine à l'été sur
le banc des accusés sur les réseaux
sociaux hier à sion n'est pas en fin
c'est insupportable en même temps c'est
la droite sur sa masse idéalement vous
avez déjà klein fait la morale toute la
journée à fait la même chose vous ne
mettez pas de masquer la plupart du
temps
ils sont mordus convient donc ce n'est
pas un enterrement comme les autres donc
c'est pour ça c'est parce que justement
le titre voilà un il dit le contraire il
dit que lui aussi avait fait le choix de
bassac signer et que ça n'aurait rien
changé il a le droit d'avoir ce ce
positionnement il faut le respecter
c'est tout guillaume sans vraiment agacé
parfois
comme toile attaque menée par des gens
qui sont comme ça et je connais plein de
gens qui n'ont pas acquis que ça saoule
de porter de masque qui pensent que ce
qui se passe ça n'a aucun sens il ya des
restrictions qui sont complètement
absurde là je vois qu'il ya des jauges
dans les rassemblements au lieu de
disperser les personnes il y met tous au
même endroit face et n'importe quel sort
un effectif
guillaume c'est un entrepreneur c'est à
dire qu'elle s'y à new york il va au
restaurant de la bernerie en retz
jusqu'à
dites vous bien pour l'état dites vous
bien dans l'état qui les lui ça un
privilégié l'a bien fait sa vie il est
dans un état de colère imaginez le mec
est tout en bas et jean kiffer rien qui
va pas en restant qui valurent quils on
lui a dit ta vie c'est fini tu attends
tu restes chez toi enfermé et tu
t'attendais tu bouges pas de chez toi on
te dira quand est ce que tu voudras donc
un peu d'accord avec lui mais moi je
suis d'accord avec lui sauf que sur
l'église non alors que je suis d'accord
avec lui bizarre mais comment ben slama
chrono canon s'est pas fait mais les
sondages c'est pas la
victoire d'un peuple à tourner à tous et
que ça comme on regarde tous les
sondages qui a eu dans les élections
d'avant c'était pas celui qui était
alors m'aidera fait
baigner après ma chérie je vais dire un
toit y ait une faute pénale il est entre
25 et 27 % je suis
aperçu mais ça n'est qu'un pur non sens
verte au niveau des
comment niveau des chiffres très sympa
je
comprends pourquoi est en faillite
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'à lyon emmanuel macron
monte dans les sondages pourquoi oui
mais ils montent parce que c'est vrai
que là la majorité des français sont
d'accord écrit mais la minorité
silencieuse et de moins en mars et la
filiale à 75% qui votent pas pour le
bois et cette minorité commence à être
exaspérés par ce qu'il a clivé moi c'est
ça qui me choque démocratie sécurité
alors
elle a raison mais vous savez on aime
très peur passée bon ben tu changes les
alliances faites attention aux années
ans est estimé à lyon
c'est macron c'est maryse va se
retrouver dans la merde ça se trouve à
voter à contre à contrecoeur se plaint
pas des gens qu'on alors on n'aurait pas
voulu qu'ils soient la route personnes
la
conjoncture alors déjà qui êtes vous
même aviez vous fait les crèches où ces
mots ou mme le pen devait faire quoi si
la zemmour et les peines à plat plein de
gens mais ça va pas plaire d'argent
belle et je parle des éditions mais non
mais où il était de croire que macro il
est réélu d'office messager dans les
yeux mais vous pas vous la dire ça j'ai
dit ça va vraiment me dit il et promet
de rassembler ces bons série animée de
panique sont pas du tout ça d'autant
plus que pour une mi temps mais la
maîtrise est vrai qu'il a pris trois
points dans les sondages après sa
déclaration n'aurait cru que ce serait
le contraire mais c'est vrai que ces
baromètres déjà cette troisième dose
c'est le défi du gouvernement c'est
cette troisième dose là vous verrez déjà
les français déjà ils vont commencer à
se dire on s'est bien fait d'oublier
quand même il a déjà comprendre déjà la
troisième dose ce sera d'abord mon
sondage - il va être là comme on l'a
voulu aux trois dos la poule madrid mais
je parle pas d'un polo
blanc c'est pour devenir pôle un nom
[Applaudissements]